Many people around the world still ride bikes without protective helmets.
In Sweden, only 20% of bike riders wear a helmet...
...even though physicians say that bike falls are very dangerous...
...and some of them end with fatal injuries.
Such as when a bike is rear-ended by a car.
This simulation shows how important it is to have a head protection.
Anticipating the impact of a crash or a fall,...
...a sensor in the protective collar triggers the air bag.
The collar was designed by Terese Alstin and Anna Haupt from the Swedish town of Malmö.
As students of industrial design,...
...they started thinking how nice it would be to have an invisible bike helmet...
...not messing up your hair.
They turned it into a university graduation project...
...and an independent Swedish organization for supporting inventions...
...gave them a grant of 100,000 Swedish crowns to develop the idea.
Their company, Hövding, now employs 13 people...
...and hopes to market their product sometime next spring.